your argument on it taking a while for
it to go back to recovering from this is
it based on the fear people now have
that's going to take a while to recover
from still the concerns are being around
too much traffic we're not gonna go back
in the habit of going to sporting events
games are you saying the habits and the
fears of people's gonna take us to go
back to business as usual are you saying
more the financial decisions we're
making right now of these businesses
going out of business going to take us
to recover which part are you kind of
saying is it more mindset or is there
more business well you you've described
waves 1 and waves 2 there's going to be
an initial reticence and fear among
people in terms of being in in densely
populated events where whatever they may
be
so that's your initial fear factor but
what I'm speaking of is what comes
behind this is a realization on the part
of your average working American that
they need to save more in the future
that they will never again wake up and
say why am i feeding my family ramen why
didn't I think to why didn't I set money
aside in my last life is that a good
thing oh I think it's eventually going
to be a great thing but it is going to
mean that there's that the coming
recession the recession that we already
know that we're in is going to be more
protracted and drawn-out
than what many are right now assuming as
a base case this could almost be like a
filtering process to take us back to the
habits that work you know it's are you
saying almost - you know how you talk to
the generation that came from the
depression they're always a little bit
paranoid
they're always a little bit more worried
there are always a little bit more like
cautious you know when you talk to
people older they're always a little bit
more paranoid because they've
experienced a lot more things are you
saying that this generation may pick up
a little bit of the habit and a mindset
of the Great Depression generation of
being more paranoid than before because
if that's the case I actually don't
think that's a bad thing
I don't think it's a bad thing and I
think that it's long overdue in this
country but it's going to change
the way the economy operates on a
fundamental level you're going to
perceive if you right now are stretching
your dollar to fill up your grocery cart
when this is all said and done even if
your income goes back to what it was
before hmm
you might not be saying I want the
high-rise at Disney in the full package
for the family you might get in the car
and drive somewhere and go camping if
you're at the store you might not say
you know what I'm going to buy that
lovely pork tenderloin you might buy the
pork chops you might be more frugal in
the way you approach everyday purchases
because you were forced into being
frugal because of this because you were
forced to overnight make a budget and
live within it
[Music]